the simple part that most people don't
understand
is that every thought we think in every
word we
speak is creating our future
when life calls us
that's when we have to answer one of my
thoughts about life
is that only good lies before me and
i've been saying this for
many years so it doesn't really matter
to me
what happens in life because i know it's
going to be good
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation
top
and men 10. men
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best louise hay and my take on her top
10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one be aware
of your thoughts the simple part that
most people don't understand
is that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future it's as though
our thoughts
go out into the universe and are
accepted
and brought back to us as experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought
and every time you speak a word you are
literally
painting your future making your dinner
whatever you want to call it you are
creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple but it's not
easy to accept but once you accept it
then you can start deliberately creating
what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware of what you
don't want in your life and how you are
contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for
some reason in the last 20 years the
universe has wanted
this to go out among all the people or
all the people that are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do
to begin to train yourself to be aware
of
what you're thinking and and one of the
ways to do that
is to periodically say to yourself what
am i thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin
on the smallest level to be aware of our
thinking
we can start to make changes rule number
two forgive yourself
a lot of people say i don't want to look
at the past my childhood was miserable
and i never want to think about it again
well then it's very important that you
start forgiving because forgiveness sort
of wipes the slate clearly
so that other things can come in yeah
yeah well the tapping setup phrase right
is
even though i have whatever the problem
is i love and forgive myself i accept
adore myself where i love and approve of
myself yes right off if the
that's to me like the mirror work that i
do we'll have people do
also is to look in the mirror and look
into your own eyes and start with
something really simple but difficult
like i love you i
really really love you and most people
can't do that at all because it's just
too painful yeah they have all these
messages back here that says you're no
good and you can't be in
besides you your makeup isn't on right
or you forgot to shave today or
something you know
but once you can do that if you do it
over and over again for a while
it's like you connect on a different
level with that inner child
who's been waiting for years and years
and years for you to acknowledge it yeah
and something happens and i couldn't
tell you what it is
but i have learned that the people who
do their affirmations
in front of a mirror make much quicker
progress than other people yeah
i guess it just it pushes through rule
number three
serve others when life calls us
that's when we have to answer people say
how did you do
everything that you did well i answered
the telephone
and opened the mail and did what it what
was in front of me
and then life would give me something
else to do and something else to do
and it's interesting because it's now
been i think 25 years since i wrote
the second book you can heal your life
and in
that period of time i
that book alone has sold 40
million copies worldwide
[Applause]
[Music]
and i feel i've always felt that i
didn't do anything
to promote it at all it's just life took
over and life said this book is going to
go to this country and this book is
going to go to this country
and go to this country and it's gone
many many places all over the world i
even have
two chinese versions there's the chinese
version of
uh traditional china and then there's
the chinese version of the
taiwan which is the new china
you never know where life is going to
take your work
and i think that it's important that you
don't go into it to say how much money
can i make oh i'm going to be rich i've
got to do this
because books don't make you that rich
but what they do is open the world to
you
and my thought has always been how can i
help the people
how can i help the people and i think if
you come from that point of view
it becomes a lot easier rule number four
express
gratitude gratitude works a lot
if just being grateful for everything
the more
i always say the universe loves
gratitude the more you're grateful
for what the good is in your life
the more good you get to be grateful
about and it's it's like you know if
somebody gives you a present in your
or gives me a present and i say oh my
god i hate that color and it doesn't fit
and you know
that person will never give me another
present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you i really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude
also if you want to have more self
belief and self confidence
i've designed a special free program to
help you
get it where i send you a video every
day for 254 days
the research says it can take up to 254
days for you to build a new habit and
this program will help you get it once
again it's free and the link to join is
in the description below
i think that everything you think and
everything you speak
goes out from you into the universe and
comes back
to you multiplied loving yourself
is the most powerful thing we can do
what good
is a nice car if you are full of
resentment all the time
rule number five love yourself for those
of people that have tried to change
their thinking but seem to be
stuck and can you give them some advice
to help them to be more positive or to
get through well i don't think that
they've been trying and they're stuck
i think they just haven't tried because
if you will practice
this even a small amount it makes a
difference
i have a simple exercise i give
everybody and some people say oh that's
so stupid it's so silly
but i ask them to look in the mirror
especially first thing in the morning
and just look in their eyes and
say their name and say i love you i
really really love you
and this is enormously hard for most
people to do to begin with
but as you continue to do it it makes a
big difference
you see life loves you life really loves
you
but if you don't love yourself it's very
hard for life to bring you the goodies
because you've got this wall up so when
you can learn to love who you are
and that's the way you were born when
you were a little tiny baby and when i
say you i mean everybody listening to
this
uh we all adored ourselves we loved our
bodies we loved every part of ourselves
and then we started to listen to other
people who told us we weren't good
enough
or we didn't do it right or no no no
and so we decided that maybe we weren't
very good
and that's where we get all mixed up but
when we can get back to that point of
just
adoring this marvelous critter in here
then life says oh they've she's got it
she's got it let's give her goodies
and then the next step is to be very
grateful about it
yes when you're really grateful then
they want to give you more
rule number six open up to change when i
work with people when i
workshops or classes or anything i
always try to get people just to open
their arms so that we can let the new
and remember this is the subconscious
mind and this is where we're holding
so this is saying nothing new will get
in so i always like to feel
that i'm open and receptive to new ideas
and i'm willing to learn and i'm willing
to change and i'm willing to grow
and sometimes i don't want to and
sometimes it hits areas that i
don't really care to change at the
moment and you know that's
always an area that i know is important
for me to work on
rule number seven reevaluate your
beliefs
to me i think enlightenment is letting
go
of all the things we believe that are
not
benefiting us us in life or the barriers
to
our life to the good things in life and
to release them one by one and to think
i don't have to believe that anymore or
do i want to believe that anymore
and making a conscious choice when we
can understand that
every single thing we believe has been a
choice
and it may or may not be true it can be
true for you and not for you
because it's your belief system and your
belief system and then i have my belief
system
i say a lot uh that may be true for you
it's not true for me i may not say that
out loud
but people are doing things they're
saying things and i think that to myself
a lot
and also it has nothing to do with me
whatever's going that has nothing to do
with me because i'm under
the law of my own consciousness this is
my pathway
and you have your pathway you have yours
everybody does
so we're all on a journey and i think
the more conscientious we are about it
and the more conscious
choices we make the better our journey
is or the easier or the swifter or that
we get more goodies or
we have better health rule number eight
have a positive mindset
if you have very strong beliefs within
you
that you don't deserve good things in
your life
and a lot of people have that then there
can be delays
and sometimes people say well
affirmations don't work i've done them
but when they're doing for instance
prosperity affirmations
and they've done some prosperity
affirmations and they say it doesn't
work nothing's happening and i say well
all right
how many prosperity affirmations did you
do in a day
and they'll say three probably and they
say all right how many
poverty affirmations did you do this day
and that could be 300 depending on where
you're coming from
and what are is running through your
mind
see i have this one of my thoughts about
life
is that only good lies before me and
i've been saying this for
many years so it doesn't really matter
to me
what happens in life because i know it's
going to be good
rule number nine accept your uniqueness
remember little tiny babies when they're
born
they absolutely adore themselves and
they're totally open
and they're full of love they
express themselves freely they ask for
what they want
they love their bodies from the top of
the toe to the top of their head to the
tip of their toes
and every point in between including
their own feces which they'll gladly
rub all over their bodies because
nobody's taught them guilt and shame
they know how wonderful they are and
then somewhere along the line we get
this idea
that we're not good enough and we start
putting our tape
tape measures around our waistline to
tell us if we're acceptable
or we read magazines that say we have to
be a certain height or a certain weight
before we're acceptable
or we listen to the media that says we
have to use a certain deodorant before
we're acceptable
you know it just doesn't make sense
we are absolutely divine magnificent
expressions of life
all of us and like when we were in the
circle looking at each other
we each face is another unique
expression of god
and we're not supposed to be alike since
time began on this planet there have not
been
two snowflakes alike and there's
certainly not been two people alike
and we're always trying to be like
everybody else so we're acceptable
our uniqueness is what makes us
wonderful
so we want to love that and cherish it
and acknowledge it
you see if we really believe in our
uniqueness
and the wonder of each being then there
is no competition
and no comparison there can't be we're
just
different and we're meant to be
different and that's wonderful and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is have fun i went to a chinese face
reading class recently
and one of the things they talked about
was a
bossy woman cheekbones and i said that's
me
that's me that's me
woman cheekbones cheekbones and
all my life i used to call them polish
cheekbones now i know they're bossy
woman cheekbones
but in and also in chinese uh
astrology i'm a fire tiger
now the tiger is a very strong
personality and a fire tiger is
a very strong personality and
but in the early days in china they used
to kill
the girls who were fire tigers because
they didn't want them to grow up and
tell people what to do
ah so this time i've come
forth and i get to be who i am a fire
tiger with bossy woman cheekbones
that is so cool now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you going to
take action on it
this week when you schedule in what day
what time and what place you're going to
take action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan
and when you share your plan publicly
and have some accountability you
increase your chances even further
of actually following through so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
every single thought we have or
every sentence we speak is an
affirmation and it's either positive or
negative
and it's going out from us and it's
creating our experiences
however when we talk about doing
affirmations what we're talking about
is making definite positive statements
to create something in our life or to
remove
something in our life you see if you
stand there and say
i don't want this job or i don't want
this relationship or i don't want these
hips or i don't want whatever
that does not get you what you want
that's what i call
fighting the negative and it doesn't do
anything
but keep what you have that you say you
don't want
however if you start saying and doing
affirmations that i have
a wonderful new job or i have this most
absolutely marvelous relationship then
you're beginning
to create what it is you do want
affirmations are like planting seeds
and if you think for a moment when you
put a seed in the ground you do not get
instant tomato plant or instant
strawberries or instant oak tree
that seed goes in the ground and it has
to germinate
that's the first thing which means it
breaks open its little shell
and little roots begin to go down and it
gets
nourishment from the earth and only then
does the first little chute come up
through the ground
now when we're doing affirmations too
often people say well that is the
million dollars and they stomp on that
first little shoot
they don't give it a chance to grow
[Laughter]
doing affirmations is like planting a
seed in the ground
and watering is it it is like repeating
your affirmations
and you just keep doing them and you
keep doing them and you keep doing them
and it doesn't matter whether you see
the results or you don't see the results
and sometimes it just takes time
and too many people will do affirmations
for two or three days and say see it
doesn't work
you know if
[Music]
everything happens in the perfect time
space sequence and we want to trust that
and we want to know that
so if you begin to do affirmations for
yourself
and i think it's important that we do
that on a daily basis
decide what you want and begin
to do positive statements in present
tense for what you want you never want
to say i will have
or i'm going to have because if you do
that it keeps it in the future
and remember if you say i have a
wonderful new apartment
and you're living in a dump it doesn't
mean that this is not a true statement
it means you are
planting the seed that will germinate
and grow and become the new apartment
so you just keep doing it no matter what
where you are
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there